- Have you ever stressed
out about sending an email?
Rereading it to see if it sounds okay
or wondering if you added
too many exclamation points?
Or maybe you feel confident
when expressing yourself
via text message,
but you just can't seem to find the words
when it's time to make a phone call.
But it isn't just about who
you're communicating with
or whether there's a
screen separating you.
The TIME that passes
between each chunk of
language makes a huge impact.
(pensive music)
(clock ticking)
See, I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky
and this is "Other Words."
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] "Other Words."
- Think about speaking
or signing face-to-face
or talking on the phone.
These are forms
of synchronous communication,
conversations where all the
speakers are participating
at the same time.
Asynchronous communication,
on the other hand
involves time passing
between conversational turns.
That could be a few minutes
when you shoot a quick reply
back to an email
or even weeks between sending
and receiving a letter.
Synchronous communication
tends to use signed
or spoken language
while most asynchronous
conversation happens
in written form.
It would be pretty weird
if I said "Hi to you"
and then waited around a few
hours for you to respond.
This difference allows
synchronous communication
to carry layers of meaning
that asynchronous conversation
can't do as easily.
Intonation or altering the pitch
of our voices can convey
emotion, add emphasis
and even indicate
whether something's a
question or a declaration.
Sign Language users can express
these messages in the speed
and size of their signs,
but intonation carries a lot
of subtle context about
what an utterance means.
It's the difference between
"Come see me in my office!"
and "Come see me in my office."
Though incomplete, there are
ways we try to replicate tone
in asynchronous written communication.
Punctuation helps us
denote that we're asking
a question, where we might
otherwise use up speak.
We can italicize words for emphasis,
type in all caps to indicate shouting
or even use mixed case to connote
a sing-songy mocking tone.
But written language
doesn't perfectly replicate
all the different nuances when we speak.
Think about how hard it is to show sarcasm
through writing, and when we
don't all share the same ideas
about how to visually
represent tone, well,
that's why some people
still send those ominous
text messages with a period at the end.
Synchronous communication also
gives us immediate feedback
when our conversation
partners use "backchanneling".
Nodding, saying "Mm hm,"
"Okay," or "Really,"
while other people are speaking
gives them real-time confirmation
that they're being heard
and understood.
And speaking of nods,
synchronous conversation
is full of gesture.
The ways we move our
bodies, especially our hands
when speaking can add emotional context
to the words we're saying
and even convey ideas not
easily expressed through speech,
like when you're trying
to come up with a word
but you can't quite... y'know.
Some gestures which linguists
call emblems carry meaning
without us having to speak at
all, like a thumbs up for yes
or shaking your head for no.
Gestures help a listener
more fully understand
what a speaker is trying to say.
But research shows that
gesture also helps the speaker
with cognition and fluency.
Blind speakers,
even those who have never
seen gestures produced
will regularly gesture when speaking.
But even without these linguistic tools,
asynchronous communication
has its own advantages.
A time gap
between conversational
turns can give us space
to look up extra information,
double check our spelling
and read over our message a time
or five to really perfect
what we want to say.
Asynchronous communication
can also do away
with filler words, those ums
and likes, and you knows,
we use when we're trying
to complete a thought.
Fillers serve a useful linguistic purpose
when we're thinking,
but not done speaking.
They let others know that it's still
our conversational turn, but since no one
is likely to interrupt
you when you're writing
a letter, there's no
need to fill the pauses
while you find the words
you're looking for.
With all these differences in synchronous
and asynchronous
communication, it's no wonder
that sending an email to your
coworker feel so fraught.
Especially in this always
online, work from home era,
written communication doesn't feel quite
so asynchronous anymore.
Text messages may
technically be asynchronous
but if you've ever been left on read,
you know that we send texts with the hope
of getting quick replies
and even having exchanges in real-time.
Same thing with instant messaging apps
like Slack, Teams or Discord.
If your boss Slacks you a question instead
of sending it in an email,
it probably feels like they
want an immediate response.
Conversely, supposedly
synchronous forms like cell phone
and Zoom calls tend to have a slight delay
that can throw a wrench into
the normal conversational flow.
People are more likely to talk
over each other and backchanneling
and filler words are less precise to use
which means that the ways that, sorry.
No, no, you go.
Oh, okay.
I was just gonna say
that the ways we communicate
start to blend our toolkits
for asynchronous and
synchronous communication.
Take the length and formality
of conversational turns.
Some people message in long paragraphs
with full punctuation while others send
off several quick bursts
of texts in a row.
Text reactions like pinning
an exclamation point
or a haha to another person's
message can also function
as a form of backchanneling.
According to linguists
Lauren Gawne and Gretchen
McCullough, we're even using
emojis as a form of gesture,
both literally like the
thumbs up, clapping hands
or fingers crossed emoji.
And in more figurative
and innovative ways.
We don't have an IRL equivalent
of the upside down smiley face,
or a string of flame emojis
but they have broadly understood
meanings and text form.
As McCullough writes,
"These emojis don't stand
in for individual words.
Instead, they make writing
feel a lot more like talking."
We can take some of these
semi-synchronous tools
into other contexts
where they can be useful.
Think voice notes, which
add intonation back
to asynchronous text conversations
or a zoom call where instead
of taking yourself off mute
just to say mmm, you can
now react with an emoji.
As the tools and timelines
we use to communicate change,
the ways we use language are
evolving right along with them.
And while we've all felt the friction
of switching between
asynchronous, asynchronous
and semi-synchronous tools,
we're developing our
linguistic toolkits to be able
to communicate more clearly all the time.
(upbeat music)
See?